bei aller freude für martin schulz sie
muss das letzten sonntag eigentlich
schon sigmar gabriel gewesen sein
diese explosion der guten laune nur weil
er ein sack haut was für eine gefühllose
volkspartei dieser spd findet auch hazel
drucker martin schulz kommt sigmar
gabriel geht bedeutet das abschied
nehmen von der spd wie sie kannten und
liebten hoffnungslos und schlecht
gelaunt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
finde ich mich ein bisschen respektlos
sieht man gab er gegenüber dass wir hier
den neuen so abfeiern während er
verabschiedet wird
eigentlich nicht denn sigmar gabriel war
nicht ganz unumstritten als ich war
nicht unbedingt ein freund von sigma
erreicht punkte auch nicht meinen neuen
freund während man ex-mann die
umzugskisten auf dem haus yahoo sucht
also das hat mir neuen welten wert ist
in alten- und einschläft die
umfrageergebnisse sind so dass wir jetzt
eigentlich neuen zeiten entgegengehen
erkennen in den augen der spd sigmar
gabriel als falsch gemacht wenn ich das
alles richtig gemacht und gute frage
es ist ein rückblick war auf alle fälle
richtig man ist ja auch nicht während
man sein großes geschäft verrichtet
gerade muss ich natürlich so dass wir
hier schon wieder etwas mehr hören aus
einem zukünftigen programm
dieses super gut drauf die
verabschiedung von sigmar gabriel freue
ich mich natürlich vor allem auch heute
[Musik]
matthias stadler gerechtigkeit auf die
frage wie gerecht fanden sie den umgang
mit sigmar gabriel auf einer skala von 0
gar nicht gerecht 10.10 aber sich gar da
geht ja nur von 0 1 aber gerecht dann
haben wir andere auffassungen aber das
ist ja auch sozialdemokratie oder fand
unterschiedliche auffassungen von
empirisch belegten fakten hat genau die
spd so attraktiv wie schon lange nicht
mehr
kann man da noch von der alten plante
sprechen oder ist es mittlerweile eher
so eine zärtliche cousinen schon hoch
dass die spd jetzt durchgeht ich bin aus
italien wir haben wahlen am kommenden
wochenende aus dem saarland kommen sagen
sie da ist man ja auch oftmals mit
cousinen im näheren kontakt zu ihr
lieblings familienmitglied mein liebling
familienmitglied wollte nur noch meine
mutter ich mag die gabriels attitüde
also der tut nicht so als wäre gut drauf
er tut nicht so als gegen einen grund
fröhlich zu sein
wo sind denn hier eigentlich alles so
fröhlich wie gerade total fröhlich guten
kaffee aber der gewinnung ist gleich
große tiefer geworden ohne sigmar
gabriel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sicher kann er nicht